ataque bomba en damasco con un autobús
que supuestamente transportaba soldados
del ejército sirio y que ha despertado
viejos miedos tras cuatro años sin un
suceso así en la capital del país cuando
el autodenominado estado islámico mató
al menos a 30 personas cerca del palacio
de justicia así que ahora obama barack
obama hoy una fuerte explosión cerca de
mí al principio no sabía cuál era el
origen pero cuando miré más cerca vi que
el objetivo era un autobús que
transportaba soldados hacía mucho tiempo
que no ocurría algo similar espero que
esta explosión sea la última
y
me desperté y dean autobús en llamas que
se detuvo tras chocar con la acera más
tarde oí el sonido de una segunda
explosión pero este no fue tan grande
como la primera
y
este es el primer ataque de este tipo
que sufre damasco desde que el jefe del
gobierno bashar al asad tomó el control
total de la ciudad en 2018 tumbando el
último bastión de los rebeldes en los
alrededores a pesar de que hasta el
momento nadie ha reivindicado el ataque
el gobierno mató a ocho personas en la
región de idlib controlada por las
milicias rebeldes que ya han ejecutado
ataques similares en el pasado siria
lleva más de diez años sumida en una
guerra civil que según la organización
naciones unidas- ha dejado al menos
350.000 muertos algunas organizaciones
de defensa de los derechos humanos
duplican esta cifra y la tachan de una
de las peores crisis humanitarias del
mundo